she is a free willed adult
but they've been together since 2020 when she was age 21 and he was 39
when you're 21
your brain isn't even fully developed
and the part of your brain that is left yet to develop
is the part of impulse control and decision making
so these older men find young beautiful women who seem like fully functioning
free willed adults
they enter them into marriage
lure them with this promise of how great their life is gonna be
she gets to be a permanent co host of his podcast
well if they got married on her family's farm in Georgia
it sounds like she kinda comes from money
so it sounds like he's some regular ass dude who found some reality TV fame
and hooked up with a girl who actually has some substantial
good to bring to this relationship
and hearing some of the shit he said regarding their relationship
like oh she brings the best out in me at fucking 40 something
you didn't know how to bring the best out in yourself
you need a 25 year old
21 when you first dated woman
young woman to bring the best out in you sir sir
fucking bear all day